um as you know
there's going to be downsizing and you
have made my life
so much easier
in that I am going to have to let you go
first
what why
well theft
stealing
um what am I supposed to have stolen
Post-it notes
Post-it notes what are those worth like
50 cents 50 cents yeah you steal a
thousand Post-it notes at 50 cents a
piece and you know you've made a profit
margin you know go run us out of
business Pam
paper clip and now you're firing me
but the best thing about it is that uh
We're not gonna have to give you any
severance pay
because that is
gross misconduct and uh let's just clean
out your desk
I'm sorry
human ex-punk
surprise it's a joke we were joking
around see okay he was in on it he was
my accomplice and
there was just kind of a morale booster
thing and we were showing the new guy
around kind of kind of giving him the
feel of the place
so
God you were we totally got you you're a
jerk
I don't know about that
well
I guess this is it
hey will you guys let me know if this
ever airs
thank you
all right oh
this is gonna feel so good getting this
thing off my chest
foreign
no he wasn't sad
he was full of Hope
about Colorado
and he was hoping to get an upgrade as
an awards member
and he said he was just real excited to
get home and see Holly
[Music]
just just just just just
oh
don't you know what I'm doing
yeah but you could tell
what is that why are you why are we
going in the bathroom I thought this is
where you liked your privacy
what is coming to you no no no no what
come on let's go back to the party oh
come on wait we're missing everybody
don't take that no stop it stop it no no
no no means please don't
right here I'm not gonna slam you
against anything you're acting
inappropriate
get out of my way
this is where I fell in love with you
and this is where I ask you to marry me
it started
[Music]
laughs
Holly black
marrying me will you be
my wife be coming
he will I
[Applause]
congratulations thank you so guys guys
guys guys we're moving to Colorado
all of us yep wait what Holly has to go
back to Colorado I'm going with her I'm
leaving
thank you
there she is Jan Levinson first thing in
the morning love to start my day with a
haughty bowl of Jan Michael just call me
11-7 in the morning baby Michael yes
I'm here to tell you that we are closing
this Granton branch
the board voted last night to close your
branch
on homes Authority
the boards
what
I'm very sorry I
I don't relish telling you this
you've been a big part of this company
and the board asked me to thank you for
your years of service
a small number of people will be
transferred to the Stanford branch and
the rest will be getting Severance
packages
am I a small number person or a
severance package person well we haven't
made final decisions about Personnel yet
but you're a severance package person
oh my God your branch has been doing
great lately
and your sales staff is reporting very
strong numbers
outperforming last year in fact
um and I don't know exactly how to put
this
but
what are you doing right
right what Utica Albany all the other
branches are struggling but your branch
is reporting strong numbers
look you're not our most traditional guy
but clearly something you are doing
is right and I just I need to get a
sense of what that is
David here it is My Philosophy is
basically this and this is something
that I live by
and I always have and I always will
don't
ever
for any reason do anything to anyone for
any reason ever no matter what
no matter where
or who or who you are with
or or where you are going or
or where you've been
ever
for any reason whatsoever sometimes I'll
start a sentence and I don't even know
where it's going I just hope I find it
along the way
like an improv conversation
improvisation
this is going to sound sort of high
maintenance but could we have it like
three degrees cooler in here I always
think better when it's cooler
here's the thing Michael is doing
something right and and this economic
climate no method of success can be
ignored it's not really time for
executives to start getting judgmental
now it's Hail Mary time hey
what say we order up some pasta
let's say we do
all right
she was once my girl and she is your
girl now
wow yeah this is totally unnecessary
you're not prone to seizures no